notre amour sera une bonne idée des
niveaux effet à la viola c'est un pari
un peu fou que le roi de navarre et
trois de ses compagnons se lancent un
pari rendu impossible avec l'arrivée de
la princesse de france et trois de ces
dames avec peines d'amour perdues hervé
van der meulen met en scène une pièce
peut monter en france
une oeuvre de william shakespeare qui
fait appel à la jeunesse dans la
distribution baiia des anciens comme
matisse maréchal enfin il ya des anciens
apprentis qui sont partis depuis deux
trois quatre ans notamment laurent pratx
qui joue le rôle principal qui avait
déjà joué pour nous beaucoup de bruit
pour rien qu'ils sont des anciens de
l'information dans quelques années
qu'ils sont donc réengager là comme tous
les intermittents et puis il ya une
dizaine d'apprentis de l'escadre de
l'école supérieure d'asnières une pièce
de 2h15 au rythme enlevé hervé van der
molen a fait le choix de conserver la
matière d'origine une oeuvre résolument
féministe écrite vers la fin du xvième
siècle semblait que c'était important de
montrer que shakespeare
bien avant tout le monde avait déjà
pensée féministe très forte ce qui est
d'autant plus étonnant puisque les
femmes n'avaient pas le droit de jouer
là l'époque les rôles étaient tenus par
des jeunes garçons tout ce qui est dit
sur la femme dans le spectacle dans la
pièce est magnifique vraiment un plateau
épuré pour laisser place aux textes des
incursions contemporaine peines d'amour
perdues mêle tous les arts pour
découvrir ou redécouvrir cette pièce du
dramaturge britannique
j'aime ça
la vie n'est réel qui lèsent l'ain
[Musique]